your environment has been perfectly
designed to keep you where you are but
if you start hanging around that land
you start hanging around Steve Jobs and
Elon Musk and these other people they
will pull you into a different feel the
possibility whether that's in-person
events whether that's events that you
could eventually go to whether that's
books that you can read whether that's
videos that you can watch podcasts you
can listen to to start to choose your
environment so that you're not stuck
where you are is step one and then step
two to believe in yourself is to do
difficult things a lot of the things
that we want to do will tell ourselves I
can't do that I'm too afraid to do that
it's too scary it's too difficult when I
say to myself scary difficult or hard
that means I have to do it